let's read the next thing that it asks
us it says question
um
his calculus the vehicle needs to
complete this journey within 12 hours
now just like I did before but before
you guys came in the room there's a
essential piece of information so maybe
not jot that down right 12 hours
whilst remaining under the speed limit
so I'm going to put less than 12 hours
of 90 kilometers per hour so I'm going
to say less than 90
kilometers per hour so what this is
giving us by the way does anyone know
there's a there's a name for this these
two piece information starts with a B
anyone know what it's called
if you don't know you don't even need to
know what's called but it's actually
good language for you guys to have these
are called Boundaries
right so
what we've got is we don't have a car
that can go infinite kilometers per hour
right and we also don't have an infinite
amount of time like you can't just go at
one kilometer per hour and take forever
okay so these set out upper and lower
boundaries for what values we can put
into this speed okay at what speed V
Should the vehicle be driven to minimize
the cost C whilst arriving at the
destination now remember you guys told
me right at the start right the faster
you drive the more you're going to have
to spend on petrol right but you can't
drive too slow because then you will
arrive too late does that make sense now
as soon as we know I'm trying to
minimize what's the thing that I'm going
to do to that cost function over there
I'm going to differentiate right so
let's do this
um usually you guys are used to seeing
Dy on DX but there are no wires and no
X's to be found so in fact I'm going to
be differentiating D what
DC that's the function on the left and
I'm not differentiating with respect to
X I'm differentiating with respect to V
that's my variable okay now I'm so
confident we can do this part
I will just sneakily take this and write
it as a v to the negative one why do you
think that's helpful
yeah I can just use the power law when
I'm differentiating it right so let's
just differentiate it 10v differentiate
it gives you
10 well done and then 93 000 V to the
negative one what happens to the
negative
yep so I'll go minus 93
000.
and then what happens to that negative
one that's up in your next now reduce it
so I'll go V to the negative two okay so
I've got 10 take away 93
000 on V squared are you okay with that
as a derivative
DC on David now I think I should be oh
went to a room with no eraser okay I'm
gonna get you guys while I go find a
whiteboard um eraser two once you've got
this derivative here huh
what do you do with that to find a
minimum that's what you're looking for
okay so we want we want to substitute
zero but just be careful what am I
substituting zero for like can I put
zero in here no you can't right you want
the this derivative to actually equal
zero right because what we're hoping is
we might guess that the function looks
something like this right and where we
find the derivative is zero is this
stationary Point down the bottom right
now by the way I don't actually know
that to be sure the function could look
like this for all I know if you if the
function looked like this and you found
where DC on DV equals zero what does
that tell you does that tell you the
minimum cost
it actually tells you the the maximum
cost which is a bad thing right so we're
going to have to not only find where
it's equal to zero we're going to need
to show that it's a minimum not a
maximum that's actually really important
because sometimes the minimum isn't out
like suppose this really was it right
we find a Stationary Point that's not it
what are we going to use instead it's
that word to that started with B before
right
it's the it's one of the boundaries is
going to tell us right it's either the
slowest we can possibly go or the
fastest we can possibly go one of those
will be the actual minimum okay so let
me pause right there I'm going to get a
an eraser and that'll give you some time
to get a derivative
okay this is what I've got so far can
someone tell me if I'm going on the
right track or if I'm going crazy
yeah it's my arithmetic okay so all I
did was I set this which you guys told
me was the derivative I set it to be
equal to zero because that's where
stationary points are
um I then said well I'll add this to
both sides right so that's what's put
them on opposite sides divided by 10
and then I multiply both sides by V
squared is that okay yep
so this is what I've got
yes agreement no I mean that doesn't
look like a square number to me unless
it's one I'm not familiar with you do
have to be careful though right when you
go from here to here there are two
solutions to this quadratic equation but
we only want the positive one can
someone tell me why
oh you can't go backwards presumably we
want to actually arrive at us at our
destination not um not go away from it
okay so this is what I've got okay I've
got a stationary point but what did we
say before like is this just the answer
what is by the way what can someone give
me that as a decimal what is the square
root of 9 300.
it's like 96.44
96.4 kilometers per hour okay now have a
look at this right is this okay is this
susceptible
I think if I'm not mistaken I've already
hit a problem haven't I
I'm over the speed limit right now this
is exactly what I was talking about
before right I said one of the issues
with um finding a stationary report is
you don't know what kind of stationary
point it is right you don't know if it's
a good one a minimum in this case or a
bad one right but now what I've found is
where my stationary point is not even
within my boundaries do you see that so
I'm like oh this will apparently
minimize the cost maybe we should
differentiate again let's just do that
to be sure but I can't even go at that
speed right does that make sense
let's just make sure we do know that
we're we're doing this right if I went
and differentiated again
which would give me this okay
so what happens to that 10 when you
differentiate another time
it just disappears then you get negative
two multiplied by
negative 93 000. is that okay which last
I checked will give you one eight six
thousand is that okay
V to the what happens to the power
negative three very good so
just have a look at this you don't even
need to do any kind of calculation so
you don't need a calculator right
if you take a value of V like this it's
positive right so you put it in here
can you tell me because I only care if
this thing is positive or negative it's
a second derivative so I'm trying to
work out am I concave up or concave down
which one is it
I don't even need to know its value it's
a positive number divided by
some other positive number would that
result be positive or negative
can be positive positive divided by
positive will always be positive so
you're like oh that's good
I do have a minimum right
so that is um you know when you
substitute in but it's a minimum that's
actually outside of our allowable domain
right do you remember the word domain
like where you're allowed to put in X
values in this case it's V values right
so therefore since this is too fast
what's the closest we can get to it
the closest
V to
the actual minimum
is 90 kilometers per hour
right because you can't go any faster
than that it's a bit funny isn't it
we've gone through all this work to find
using calculus what the stationary point
is but we've found is it's illegal sorry
about that right but that's your answer
right and you can test it by the way you
can just check to see if you're like I'm
not convinced this is the right answer
see this um V value we can put it into
our original cost equation do you
remember that cost was equal to oh help
me remember 10v plus 93 000 on V is that
right so you could put 90 into here
actually in fact can you can you put 90
into that tell me what you get and then
you can also put
something else like say
89 that is also another legal speed
right and C do I get something better or
do I get it worse when you put in 90
what do you get what's your actual cost
it'll be a decimal I assume
someone got it
oh
1933.3 recording cool dot dot so just
under 2 000. when you put in 89 you
notice what happens right this number
gets bigger but this number gets smaller
so that's why we use calculus but what
do you actually get what's the cost
one one are you sure
I'm like that's that's interesting
1934 was it 0.94 okay so no point there
yeah so you can see it's a dollar more
of course it's not a big difference
because it's only one kilometer per hour
difference but can you see how what
we've done is we used our our model
where you play calculus to it and then
well the calculus actually told us based
on our conditions that the optimal thing
is actually too fast so therefore we've
got to go to the speed limit that's why
the boundaries are so important
make sense
I will just say one last thing before I
send you guys off there's probably a few
lines of working that I've not written
here because I've just explained it to
you but all the logic is probably the
important part to capture right so I
hope you guys found that helpful